ciao e benvenuto ai dottori oggi andiamo
aprire i primi regali di natale noti
perché abbiamo data 8 e un bravissimo e
ci sono tante sorprese
dentro in pratica è a forma di albero di
natale infatti è il regalo ideale da
mettere sotto l'albero di natale e lo
potete trovare in edicola costa
solamente 6 euro e 90 c'è una versione
maschile in cui potete trovare le
sorprese di spider man star wars cars e
marvel è una versione femminile in cui
potete trovare le sorprese delle glee
miss 5 lupo mm ebadi il buco nominata
lotto c'è sempre un magazine allegato
ma senza un babbo natale in parità
grazie a questo diversi e noi magari mi
potete trovare tante curiosità lo sapevi
geni segreti dei fiocchi di neve mai
detto di fermo nel paese di babbo natale
di babbo natale batte curiosità
sull'inverno del natale perché la pelle
si attacca il ghiaccio biscotti di
natale
invece io ho un tutorial su come fare la
ghirlanda dell'effetto vita e inizia la
botte ora vediamo se apriamo il nostro
natal 8 alla procediamo potrebbe aprire
ai ragazzi contro allora in coda la
prima sorpresa questo vediamo un
cartello spider man attaccato al
contrario quindi va messo poi così che
viene attaccata con una ragnatela
qui visione la mia scrivania e c'è
scritto collezione a tutte le scene
sorpresa scavo stellari abbiamo studiato
così magari 38 pt chiama spero c3po 22
kg di sarah che si chiama 70 questo caso
la destra come al solito che carine e
quindi sono e se la mattina con la testa
sopra e questo è l'altro personaggino
tra dei colori sono delle matite questa
passeggiata quella persona si è fatto su
per bene
carino ma chi ci sono altre cose sono
tre
vediamo allora abbiamo il primo è tutta
wenders pure gli altri con degli
avengers epidemia mese quindi apriamo il
primo vediamo se capitan america
allora abbiamo il nostro primo supereroe
e c'è una ventosa sotto quindi si può
attaccare si può attaccare praticamente
ovunque prossimo di una supereroina
forse catwoman
guardate un po che carina e anche questa
è avventata quindi proviamo ad
attaccarla anche lei si ajerman sempre
di avengers andiamo un altro supereroe
eccolo qua in d e li attacchiamo e
sappiamo anche lui tema spider locali
stanno tutti insieme diventate disordini
di queste erano le sorprese 123456
soffrite più il magazine
questo per la versione maschile
variabile il mio parla per sé nei film
fu curiosa è sempre il magazine chiusa e
poi queste nove sere in cui mi libera
che carina curiosa andiamo da prima
iniziamo per la stretta dovrebbe rising
my god the twin trend stretto amico
tieni un personaggio in allegato
spero che ci sia un gattino ma qualsiasi
animale va bene allora vediamo vediamo
video coniglietto viola l'ultimo samurai
singh super river tante bellezze ho
corso anche metterlo come portachiavi
perché c'è il laccetto vediamo
svolgevano gambello sono vari personaggi
di fegato vari animali che vi possono
aiutare come scrissi dottor carino
abbiamo aquaria illuminano magicamente
sott'acqua
tra l'altro sono questo e costano 5 99 è
tutto il natal 8 costi 90 quindi già il
valore è più alto già solo questo questa
599 fantastico
i primi sono tante che possono aiutarci
che belle bellissime quali o il nome il
nome del singolo allora si chiamano al
gas con chiama mar in questa lingua
anche ad aprirla e poi vediamo se
l'acqua è un essere retto carine pare
c'è la coda con i glitter i brillantini
e sei tutte celeste che come sapete è
uno dei miei colori preferiti ma vediamo
di aprire le sorprese e poi li mangiamo
in alcuni di questi lunghi faccia letto
con duke e allegria and me ecco qua
abbiamo un progetto di mia and me però
questo è uno di quei braccialetti e
guarda tu lo vedi così e rimane appunto
di ritorno raccordata in immagini che
carina e poi se non sbaglio bisogna fare
così e poi così ma non si chiuderà
subire a incredibile
una volta mi ricordo se giochiamo sempre
allora innanzitutto me lo metto perché
fighissimo comunque queste erano le
sorprese dell'edizione femminile scrive
che in quello femminile perché le cose
che stavate dentro qualcosa o meglio del
filo di 690 il pc anche il magazine
quindi ottimo ora andiamo in parte della
nostra glynis nell'acqua vediamo come si
illumina
ecco qua la nostra i pm superate come si
illumina si illumina di blu
abbiamo passato la luce per farvela
vedere meglio ma poi avendo nei nostri
si possono far giocare assieme con
colori diversi
insomma fini lo trovate in vicolo al
signore una volta quasi sapere se volete
vedere altri video unboxing nostri video
regali di natale questi giorni tutti i
primissimi regali di natale in tale
senso mettendo a colorare non sono mai
lines e produrre altri unboxing e ora vi
lascio a marcato piattellina su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
video divertenti challenge slime clicca
su quello che preferite